ça fait des semaines que philippe
couillard en parler québécois devront
dit-il se serrer la ceinture
on commence le téléjournal ce soit avec
un effet bien concret de cette impasse
budgétaire à saint-bruno une garderie
flambant neuve ne pourra pas ouvrir
comme prévu ont joint à toutes les
marques ou philippe 80 familles viennent
d'apprendre la très mauvaise nouvelle
oui patrice et la garderie du boisé
enchantée qui est derrière moi 80 places
comme vous le disiez le projet
d'animation qui travaille depuis trois
ans qui avait obtenu toutes les
autorisations nécessaires du ministère
et qui avaient écouté embaucher les
éducatrices elle avait sélectionné les
enfants vous devriez voir à l'intérieur
on voit les noms des enfants sur les
différents quasi qui sont là et bien
voilà la fin de la semaine dernière on
leur apprend qu'un moratoire sur la
dernière étape qui était une étape
apparemment la qui était acquise et non
ne pourra pas donc ouvrir cette garderie
là pour mieux comprendre ce que ça
signifie pour les parents et pour
animation va les écouter nous autres on
avait donné notre notice on était en
milieu familial donc on a donné notre
notice
donc c'était pas possible pour nous de
retourner parce que on l'avait donné
deux mois à l'avancé donc les places ont
été remplacés à la garderie familiale
puis partir de l'eau c'est la seule
ressource qu'on avait c'est la garderie
privée et l'on sait pas comment gérer ça
c'est sûr que pour l'instant on accuse
le coup
on est ambivalent on sait pas est ce
qu'on cherche une place ailleurs où on
attend ici des nouvelles du gouvernement
qu'est ce qui va se passer tout ça ce
matin on a procédé à 14 mai à pied parce
que nos employés étaient déjà engagées
depuis deux semaines prêts à travailler
donc ça c'était déjà un énorme prix à
payer
ferrer pour les a vu les noms des
enfants derrière il y avait des petits
casiers donc c'est tout neuf c'est tout
près on avait eu les permis nécessaires
donc c'est gelé
on va regarder ensemble des chiffres si
vous le voulez bien il ya 220 mille
places subventionnées en garderie au
québec on en promettait et si le chiffre
en rouge
vingt-huit mille nouvelles places d'ici
et ce sont donc celle qui voit à peu
près 600 nouveaux projets ce sont ces 28
mai
nouvelles places qui sont en quelque
sorte gelé vous avez pu par l'effet
n'est pas la ministre de la famille
madame charbonneau
oui il nous dit qu'il y en aura deux
nouvelles classes patrice et nous
l'assurent mais elle dit qu'il faut
prendre le temps nécessaire pour évaluer
ce qu'on est capable de s'offrir
collectivement
si vous voulez on écouté et on sait
qu'il faut prendre des décisions et
qu'il faut regarder l'ensemble des
dossiers donc on pouvait pas le faire
quand tout était en action faut
s'arrêter bien analysé qui après se
reprendre le parcours avec toute la
délicatesse que ça va prendre mais dans
un budget réaliste est vraiment pour ce
que le québec peut se payer donc patrice
pas de décision avant que les crédits du
budget provincial qui devrait avoir lieu
qui devrait présenter au début juin ne
soient étudiées ça veut dire que les
enfants ne pourront pas faire leur
entrée ici au mieux au mois de juillet
merci philippe on va suivre ça bien sûr
on va rejoindre mon camarade regency à
québec parce que david ça c'est un bon
exemple concret de cette impasse
budgétaire
ce sont des choix que le gouvernement
pose actuellement et ce n'est que le
début là c'est le premier peut-être
résultats tangibles d'une série de
conséquences qui semble à peu près
inévitable
autre secteur à surveiller patrice celui
de la santé en santé qui accapare la
moitié des dépenses de l'état les
dépenses augmentent d'à peu près 4 7 5 %
par année donc toute velléité de réduire
cette croissance en deçà de 4 % aura des
impacts aurait des impacts tangibles
dans les semaines les mois à venir
on le sait la solution la plus simple
pour l'état c'est de geler les salaires
des fonctionnaires les syndicats eux
réclament des hausses de plus de 4%
un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui philippe
couillard a dit je ne veux pas négocier
sur la place publique mais c'est une
fleur pour le premier ministre
pas question d'en arriver à une solution
mur à mur il nous explique pourquoi ya
pas uniquement les salaires la masse
salariale c'est pas je sais salaire
individuel c'est le nombre de personnes
qui travaillent toutes sortes de
variables là bas qui nous permette qui
nous permettront je crois d'avoir une
bonne conversation
mon objectif encore une fois oui c'est
avant tout de mieux gérer des finances
publiques
mais c'est de maintenir une fonction
publique des gens qui sont au service
public engagé maintenir l' expertise
puisse faire en sorte que les jeunes il
goûte bien travaillé les services
publics du québec
mais patrice on ne fera pas l'économie
de cette discussion de ce débat là les
salaires c'est à peu près 60% des
dépenses de l'état donc oui ce sera au
coeur des pourparlers que le ministre
des finances que le président du conseil
du trésor aurons avec les grands
syndicats dans les semaines à venir et
les réponses qu'on aura aux nombreuses
questions que se posent des
contribuables on les aura vers le 3/4
peut-être 5 juin lors du dépôt du budget
du gouvernement du caire et des crédits
budgétaires merci un avis d'un québécois
bonne journée